When you love something you fight for it
we're the ones who changed everything
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new marvel eternals video for how they lead up
to mutants and x-men inside the mcu or they are
one of the ways we see mutants in x-men inside
the mcu there'll be a couple different
ways that i'll explain during the video
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll start
seeing more eternals trailers later this summer
when the black widow movie comes out when shangxi
in the legend of the 10 rings comes out so there's
a lot of really big stuff coming up we're doing a
new disney plus giveaway for memberships because
loki episodes are coming up all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know what you
want them to do with eternals inside the mcu going
forward but during the eternals trailer footage
that they release gemma chan's Sersei characters
talking to someone saying we're the ones who
changed everything both metaphorically and
literally like they went around actively changing
the course of human history and evolution but also
changed it in passive ways without completely
realizing what was going on and that's where we
get to the whole x-men and mutants of it all so in
that new eternals teaser trailer footage that they
released recently they give you an early look
at them during a couple different time periods
in their two different speeches are meant to give
you an idea for their overarching philosophy just
guiding their actions inside the mcu like what
are they doing on earth what are they here for
and why are they doing this if you've read any of
the recent or even the older jack kirby eternals
comic books you have a pretty good idea for their
origins compared to the other big marvel comic
book groups with powers like the inhumans the
x-men the fantastic four asgardians like thor
characters like the hulk and spider-man that have
biological powers marvel has a bunch of different
ways of explaining where biological powers come
from people who had their dna mutated after they
were teenagers or adults getting into accidents
monica rambo is probably the best example of that
in present day mcu during wand division she passed
through scarlet witch's chaos magic hex barrier
enough times that it completely mutated her dna
and she got powers i did a whole video on her
a couple months ago explaining why she's secretly
one of the most powerful new characters in the mcu
because of the way her powers work so
i'll link that below in the description
but monica rambo isn't a mutant in order to be
called a mutant traditionally you have to be
born with your powers so a lot of you realize that
when billy and tommy were created on one division
they actually meet that requirement so as far
as we know they're the first two characters
that we've seen that were born mutants in the mcu
technically she did use her chaos magic to create
them with a little help from hex vision although
she did most of the work so scarlet witch messing
with the hex in her chaos magic is just one of
the ways early mutants start to show up in the
marvel disney plus series eventually the marvel
movies because billy and tommy are supposed to
come back and have a minor role in doctor strange
too multiverse of madness so they can pay off that
whole one division post-credits scene with her
trying to save them from an alternate reality
the difference with the eternals influencing
the creation of mutants and x-men characters
in the mcu is actually through an accident whereas
scarlet witch was trying to create two new beings
on purpose so this is where we get into some of
the changes that the eternals movie is making to
the eternals backstory in the comics originally
the celestials were created by the cosmic entity
eternity which is the living embodiment of the
multiverse like the multiverse has a consciousness
peter quill talks about eternity during guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 he gets a glimpse of it
when ego the living planet sort of activates his
celestial dna another small change to the mcu ego
the living planet in the mcu is another one of the
celestials he's just on a twisted version of the
same mission that the regular celestials are on so
eternity created the celestials for the purposes
of gardening each universe and experimenting
with life just go around and experiment on
planets trying to create new life and see what
happens because we have the new fantastic four
movie coming galactus for example his cosmic role
is a little bit like the celestials it works hand
in hand with the celestials his cosmic purpose is
sort of weeding the garden metaphorically talking
about the universe like you do controlled
burns sometimes to recharge nutrients into
the soil that's galactus on a cosmic scale he
eats planets is a way to prevent stagnation
and overpopulation everyone posts all your thanos
memes perfectly balanced as all things should be
the other minor change that apparently they
explained during the eternals movie at least
in the mcu is that the deviants came before the
eternals and the celestials created the deviants
in the mcu in order to protect the new life
that was growing on each of the planets around
the universe at least initially the deviants were
supposed to hunt predators preying on the new life
that the celestials were experimenting with but
at some point they explained the deviants rebel
against the celestials and start killing off
all the regular life forms too so in response
the celestials then create the eternals to go
around and stop the deviants from doing that
to protect life like the way you hear ajak Salma
hayek's characters say during that trailer footage
if you love something you fight for it because
they intercut that with the footage of the wedding
that's happening on the beach they're talking
about the eternals fighting for each other like
they love each other so they're fighting for
each other but it's also a metaphor for them
loving humanity in fighting for humanity
trying to stop the deviants trying to stop
other things from killing off all life on
the planet even though the deviants are
portrayed as villains during the eternals movie
they are not the main villains technically really
the celestials are more like the main villains
if you remember the loki's speech during the
first avengers movie when he's talking to nick
fury about crushing ants under his boot and nick
fury's like wait are we the ants are you the boot
what's going on here on a more cosmic scale the
celestials are the boot and humanity earth is
the ant so like you see esau and the searcher
in the first guardians of the galaxy movie using
the power stone to wipe out an entire planet's
worth of life that's basically them getting rid
of an experiment that they feel like didn't pan
out anytime the celestials are done with an
experiment they'll just toss it in the cosmic
waste bin so to speak so during the eternals
movie not only the eternal is trying to stop the
deviants from killing humans they're also trying
to stop the celestials from threatening all life
but the way the drama between the eternals the
deviants and the celestials play out and lead
to the creation of mutants and x-men characters
inadvertently at least through an accident is
that apparently during the movie the celestials
also lay a celestial egg inside planet earth
and they're trying to grow another celestial
eventually but because it's a celestial it
takes eons for it to grow so it's just sitting
there growing inside planet earth for hundreds
of thousands even millions of years in over all
those years it slowly begins to irradiate earth's
soil with its celestial energies that is
just giving off slowly modifying human dna
until eventually humans develop the x gene
and start to be born with biological powers
it's a little like the idea that background cosmic
radiation that scarlet witch is manipulating to
modify things inside the hex like the same type
of energy that was given off during the big bang
the same energy inside the infinity stones this is
the same type of cosmic energy that the celestials
wield on a certain level but normally when you're
not scarlet witch and you don't have chaos magic
abilities it takes eons for something like this to
change dna to modify things marvel kind of did a
version of this story in the comics where they
said that celestial blood was tainting earth's
soil and that was slowly modifying human dna over
time so the movie explainer is just a little bit
different it's the exact same concept of what
happened with vibranium in wakanda the vibranium
meteorite crashes in wakanda in over thousands and
thousands of years the vibranium leeches into the
soil affecting the plant and animal dna eventually
human dna because they're feeding on all the
animals and the plants just a very scientific way
of explaining what seems like magical abilities
they do that a lot during the thor movies as well
saying oh this thing that you think is magic is
really just highly advanced science that you guys
haven't figured out yet so a lot of you are asking
if the celestials are inadvertently leading to the
creation of mutants in the mcu by slowly modifying
human dna where have mutants been this whole time
why haven't we started to see them until now there
are couple reasons as you suspected some of them
are plot armor reasons like legal reasons they
literally could not do mutants or x-men until now
in the mcu so all the marvel movies up to about
the eternals were developed starting before the
fox disney deal was done so kevin feige originally
had to develop a plan for the next five year of
marvel movies that didn't involve mutants or x-men
characters wanda vision is sort of an exception to
that with billy and tommy they kind of skated by
on that because nobody literally calls them a
mutant or an x-men character during that series
they're just born with powers everyone thinks
it's weird for a minute until they just eventually
accept it so actually using mutant characters like
mainstream big x-men characters and movies takes
way longer because the movies take a long time
to develop and they couldn't start developing
those movies until after the disney fox deal was
done so that's why we probably won't be seeing a
ton of traditional full-blown mutants x-men
characters running around the marvel movies
till at least around 2023-2024 so that's like
black panther ii territory fantastic four movie
the later movies that are coming out so just tune
your expectations accordingly for that that's why
kevin feige says they haven't even gotten close to
casting a new version of wolverine because they're
literally just starting to develop the new marvel
x-men movie right now but on a story level the way
they justify mutants just starting to show up now
is mostly the concept that that growing celestial
egg deep in the planet's surface took eons to
modify human dna to the point where eventually
people just start being born with powers if
that's just starting to happen after the events
of avengers end game like we're just now starting
to see it then there's the way they're mining the
snap avengers infinity war the events of avengers
end game for drama in the later movies influencing
the future of the mcu really good example is that
rocket claims in avengers end game that the cosmic
energy given off by a single infinity gauntlet
snap is so massive that it's never been seen on
that scale before in the history of the universe
and there were three infinity gauntlet snaps
within the span of five years all on planet earth
in close proximity to each other so those also
act as a catalyst for change affecting everything
in the future in unexpected ways but the writers
essentially use events like that to connect
these new weird concepts and these new weirder
characters to all the stuff that's come before
like the marvel phase one phase two phase three
characters as we get more eternals trailer videos
i'll do more videos on the other characters as
well like kitt harrington's black knight character
he's going to be really cool in the mcu his main
weapon the ebony blade is kind of like a storm
breaker level weapon inside the mcu it also has
some of the same abilities that stormbreaker has
and of course we have all the loki episodes coming
up in a couple weeks i'll be doing videos for each
of those episodes congratulations mr j juck you're
the giveaway winner from my last big marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click here
for my full marvel eternals trailer breakdown that
big marvel phase 4 trailer and click here for
my new thor 4 love and thunder first look video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!